late on this video i know man like
really late am i as late as i am for
long halloween
part two
i don't know probably not but i just saw
val and it's pretty impactful and i have
to talk about it because i want to talk
about it and that's the fun of doing
things like this you get to talk about
what you want to talk about sometimes
sometimes talking movies is just work
this is not one of those times let's do
it
[Music]
so val is a peek into the life and
career of val kilmer not really a
documentary not a biopic but an
introspective peek into his life from
his perspective
using
stock footage that he's had because you
ever think to yourself like man it'd be
so awesome if you can chronicle
someone's life with a video camera
no we don't do that now we do social
media posts or vlogs and it's a little
different people make social media posts
or videos or they do vlogs but they're
really polished you know they have
polished editing
it lacks that grit it lacks the
imperfection
that is the realism of life but val
kilmer was one of those people
throughout his life and career he had a
camcorder he would talk to the camcorder
give his thoughts he would talk to his
castmates and on one hand absolutely it
is cool to be like oh whoa that's kevin
bacon and they're just hanging out and
talking and chilling you have that
connection where you can recognize
you're like oh that's from ghost in the
darkness oh wow that's from heat it's
very honest in that respect it's val
kilmer's life as seen by val kilmer and
i appreciate that kind of honesty it's
not like you know you've seen him right
those documentaries are like this is a
documentary and it's objective it's like
nah it's kind of a propaganda piece
based on your perspective and your
opinion and the reason i love this peek
into val kilmer's life is because it's a
peak you never really get to see used to
be the oh no matter who the famous
person is you don't really know their
personal lives while that maintains to
be true
no matter who the person is people on
your social media whoever they are and
the posts they make you still don't
really know their personal lives they
put their best witty post forward but
it's really not the grit of them and in
many ways this movie isn't always that
either but there is an honesty to it
when he talks about hey i'm going
through my divorce and he talks about
batman you know like he was like oh i
jumped at the opportunity to be batman
because every little boy wants to be
batman and then he's like every boy
wants to be batman but they don't
necessarily want to play batman in a
movie because val kilmer was a dude he
liked experiencing characters he liked
putting a piece of him in the character
getting a little piece back he liked
really
he liked using
acting as a form of evolution you know
it's like katamari damashi you know it's
like he would like to annex roll over a
character and annex that into a piece of
him until he just became larger and
larger
you know spiritually speaking he was
like batman i was just in the rubber
suit and jim carrey and tommy lee jones
were really putting a lot of them into
it and they were making the characters
larger than life and he was like i just
had to stand there and i he felt like a
prop that's interesting to me that's
fascinating because you're like dude why
would you not want to be batman that's a
pretty good reason to not want to be
batman in a movie it gives a good honest
insight into the perspective of why do
people pick certain roles like the movie
the saints like why the saints why that
movie not saying it's good or bad i'm
just why this what made him go yeah i
want to do that one he gives a good
reason as to why he wanted to do that
one because he was like it's like 20
rolls in one i got to do a bunch of
different personalities and people
that's awesome sometimes the roles
actors pick it's as simple as that it's
just something they wanted to do because
they felt like it would benefit them i
mean there's benefit and then there's
benefit it's also a peak that not a lot
of people talk about which is that
element of the entertainment industry
where he was talking about in one of his
i guess their vlogs journal entries um
talking to the camera before they were
called vlogs he was talking about how
studios literally own you they own a
piece of your soul for the duration of
the filming of this movie and it's very
it's got to be a dehumanizing feeling
there's another thing i liked about the
movie it puts the person the human being
first in the career second now val
kilmer in his current situation he
survived cancer he has a stoma in his
throat it's very hard for him to talk
and when he does talk he's very hard to
understand what he's saying i try to
hear
the world
i don't wanna
survive so the movie though it sounds
like it's narrated by val kilmer is
narrated by his son and it actually it
shows his son narrating the picture you
know it shows him being the narrator
doesn't even hide it at all my name is
val kilmer i'm an actor it's like the
last narration his son has it shows he
and val kilmer hugging
and it's
i it clicked with me the connection of
this movie being between a father and
son in the end i really loved and
appreciated this peek into val kilmer's
life i love the fact that he was just
one of those people who were like i'm
gonna have a camcorder and chronicle my
life because maybe one day people will
want that i haven't met a person who
watched this movie and didn't go it was
really sad i mean it is sad touching
it's it's very heartfelt it's very
touching in a world of ever-growing
dehumanization
with our fellow human beings as we
interact online i appreciate the fact
that this movie though
editing is always a thing in a picture
like this i appreciate the fact that it
did its best to eliminate the filters
and just give you something real it's an
experience that is introspective in
itself
and in turn forces you to be
introspective in the healthiest way
possible what to write this thing i i
how do you even rate a life experience i
don't know
you know what here you go i personally
for the emotional
resonance it had with me i say val is
awesome tacular
because i felt it i felt the cries i
felt the emotional heartache of people
like have you given any of those this
year there you go i'm here to help you
with your pain but all right valace on
amazon prime right now absolutely go
check it out you'll be glad you did even
if you just watch it once have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you